so today the talk will be about the
patient claims good application and will
describe the solution that we developed
at in Mar so first I will start by
describing the problem of deduplication
and more importantly why do we need a
machine learning solution to solve this
problem I will then move to describe the
Python library that we used is called de
doop so it provides the basic breaks for
our for the solution that we developed
and then I will I will describe our own
solution that we built on top of that
library and finally I will go through
some performance numbers and what other
future improvement that we want to
introduce to our solution so first of
all I work as a data scientist with the
data science at in Mar basically it's a
minimal profit mostly software solutions
for manufacturers and retailers we are
like the middle point between these two
entities and we have three core business
networks promotion supply chain health
care whether to whenever you redeem a
coupon at at a grocery store you return
a product or you put a claim to get your
prescription medicine in Mary's
somewhere involved in the process so
with the data science team based we work
with those three core businesses to
provide model based solution and
adversity visualizations the work and
presenting today is part of them the
health care network so it's a solution
that will be used by many pharmacies and
so what's the duplication so basically
whenever you have like multiple records
that you want to group and assign them
to one representative so it can be like
you have a long list of customer
transactions you want to map all these
transactions to unique shoppers
can be like we have patient claims filed
under the same patient and also you want
to group them to 11 unique patient or
more generally when you have like
multiple records coming from different
sources and you want to merge these
records and you don't have one to have
in your petition in the these records a
more related example here is when you
have a merger of two hospitals so this
is a problem that is happening now with
all these merger between hospitals they
have every hospital there has its own
records for patient and when they want
like to merge them into one unique
record they are faced with this problem
where they have different ways to to
keep the records about their patients
and this example for you have like the
different version for the first name you
can have a match for with the social
security the date of birth and that's
not always a good already with that
difference in first and the verge of the
first name version between Vivian and
we've will will be a problem for system
that we look for an executive match more
special for our solution we've been
developing this four part of our
pharmacy financial management solutions
where we have a better base full of
claim so every every time a patient go
goes to a pharmacy order some
prescription drug a new claim is created
and what the pharmacy needed is to group
all these claims by unique patient why
they want that because there is like a
performance measure called like a
proportion of days covered that they use
to measure the medication adherence
basically a patient has a prescription
for 90 days for drugs they want to make
sure that he goes to all the duration of
the treatment they also want to make
sure that the pharmacies are doing their
part of the job in reminding the patient
tool to order his drugs and I this so
this is like if it's going to be used as
a performance measure imagine if patient
needs to go like a order his drag
three times and if he does that he has
like a hundred percent adherence if he
misses one time it would be sixty six
percent but imagine if he did order his
medicine for three times but for one of
them the claim that was created for that
patient there was some mistake in there
and it was not an exact match to the two
others so he will end up with an ideas
of sixty-six percent which is not the
real case so this is why it's important
to have a correct duplication even when
the rockers are not an exact match so in
a perfect world this problem would be
solved by by one sequel query here you
just look for the same name same date of
birth ed zip code group by those same
fields so if those same fields are an
exact match you're talking about the
same patient and move on but I'm not
coming up with any breakthrough here the
data is noisy there's so many reasons
why this exact match won't work I will
mention feel them so first one very
common a typo at the time of empty
whether it's in the in the name or any
of the other fields the records could be
coming from different sources they have
their own way of formatting the data
that's for example typical when you have
like different health institution and
they use different way to state the date
of birth put like first names and last
name or they put last name middle name
first name I mean there's so many
variation about that the data can be in
the wrong field this is also common
problem i was surprised when instead of
putting the date of birth they would put
like the the insurance card number or
worse than that when they would put
notes in the in the for example a
patient we're supposed to mail in his
medication they'll put the word mail in
in the patient name field so when you
have that I mean there is no way to get
any exact match even when you use like a
rule-based system there's so many cases
for variation that you can't come up
with all the rules that will still allow
you to find the duplicate using like a
sequel queries and let's not talk about
the different versions of name you have
like Robert draw Bob Vivian Vivian I
mean there's so many of them
and the most difficult problem is when
do you say that those these two versions
of the same name they're like the same
thing I mean you cannot come up with
that said the rule-based system you the
best way to deal with that is to come up
with model-based you duplication in the
end so where you want to build a model
you want to learn a model and make sure
that that model will read it will learn
as many variation as possible I mean
this is why machine learning is better
than you humans because it can learn so
many cases so the way to approach that
using a model-based approaches first of
all is to get a similarity function you
have two claims you want to measure
similarity between these two claims and
based on the fields that you have you
will say like these are very similar or
not similar at all after that you have
to define a threshold you say if the
similarity is above that threshold then
we will say that these two claims they
are matching their they relate to the
same patient once you have the pairwise
similarity between all the claims that
you have the next step is to do a class
drink so basically if you have a pair
pairs of matching claims and they are
made by this they're like raised to the
same patient you want to be able to
group those pairs and to build a cluster
to say for this patient a we have this
long list of claims made by that same my
patient so these are the two fundamental
step c computing similarity getting
matching and then apply some clustering
algorithm to group the the matched pairs
the problem with this approach if you
just want to apply these two basic
blocks is whenever you compute like
pairwise similarity you end up having
what we call an N square complexity and
imagine if you have a list of 1 million
claims you end up with one trillion
opera similarity operation that you need
to compute you still don't need to store
this one trillion values into memory you
only need to store the ones that are
above a certain threshold but still the
process of going in
compute all of them is not going to be a
reasonable especially that the number of
claims will keep increasing and mean any
system that you have no one to be able
to you will hit the wall at a certain
time so the way to solve that is just to
try to be a smarter about how
comparisons are done how to reduce that
number the approach that we fold here is
not to try to like find I mean I don't
think there's any linear method or n n
log n is just to divide that complexity
of n square by a big number and here
comes the package the Python package
group it's made by a group of data
scientists from Chicago they they named
their organization data made they have
that that package available on github
and they recently inked a month ago they
started a commercial service base it on
the same package that they call the job
that I oh so basically they they are
located servers and they use their their
own code to help companies used that
that package for the drooping the
lyrical by the way up I will say to
duping it's like just short waits a DD
applications the same thing what the
dupe python library does yeah there's
mainly three things see things though
it's able to find duplicate records in a
data set the other functionality is if
you have like two lists and you want to
find the matching records in this to
list that's something also you can do
with that a package and the third thing
is when you have like a list of messy
data you want to match the records in
that list to another shorter list where
we have what you got a canonical data
set you know that in that shorter list
you have unique records you want to find
the match in in those renewed crackers
in your messy data for our solution we
use the first and the third feature so
how does this package work
the Baisakhi here doesn't an example of
like say for records and we want to
compute a similarity function the first
thing is we will have a similarity
function between for each field so we'll
measure how close are the first name how
similar is the last name the addressing
and so on and our final here it's
mentioned distance but you know a
distance and similarities basically the
same thing I mean when you want to have
a short distance or a high similarity
here is an example of the comparing two
claims based on like getting the
distance between every between every
pair of the same field and the other
thing you want to have weights for every
pair why that because you can say that
the first name is the most important
field in the claim even if there is like
a small difference in the first name you
if they are pretty similar you still
want to give a higher weight to that
field done let's say the address because
you think that the address can change
there's so many variability in the
address same thing for the phone number
so the best best way to deal with that
is to get like a training data set and
try to learn those weights and that's
what did you is able to do it uses a
linear regression model that will just
based on a small set of label it pairs
and we will see that next it will try
like to render the linear regression
learn automatically those wedding models
so how the training set is built is
through a phase of active learning
basically the linear regression for the
de doop they try to look at the obvious
cases when you have like an exact match
and when you have very different fields
based on that it can learn on those
field by automatically labeling them as
matching or non matching and extract the
first version of the weights but in
order to improve that waiting it needs
like a user feedback so what it will
what we will do is whenever there is a
pair of records that it's not very sure
about it it can go like either way it
will just output that parent will ask
the user for feedback just basically you
have a pair of claims tell me if that
pair is related to the same patient or
not based on that feedback it will help
improving finding the suitable waits for
that similarity function that we just
saw the next step is the clustering so
you have like a claim a and B are
matching clay and B and C are matching
together how do you group a B and C in
the same cluster the did you play better
users and the article or a glow merit of
clustering method it basically uses the
the similarity or the pair that were
already matched what you can see here in
the graph is like me are the claims and
whenever you have like a high similarity
between the the claims you will have a
link and you'll first try to look at all
the records together and then you will
try to see like the most similar records
you're going to start agglomerating them
together until you you go through all
the records an important step for this
clustering algorithm is this is like the
threshold where do you do your cat to
say I'm going to stop stop agglomerating
claims at this level so these are going
to be my clusters and that the duduk
library offers a convenient way of
finding that a short so we've seen here
where I've so I described it how to
compute a similarity function and how to
use it clustering algorithm to find the
duplicates but we still you facing the
problem of very high complexity using
closer to algorithm so the most
important feature found in the doodoo
packages the way they try to reduce the
number of comparisons and to do that
they use what they call the predicate
blocks basically you
try to build blocks of its lack of
initial filtering try to build blocks of
similar records and try to find matching
pairs only in these blocks with this
similar example they use like the first
three letters of the address field so
any claim that starts with 160 you will
put it in a block any claim that starts
with one to see in the address in the
address field you put it in another
block now when you're trying to find
matching records you don't have to look
at all the possibilities for these four
records all you have to do is look on
each block separately so for the block
that starts with 160 we have just two
records we just going to compute one
similarity value if it's above the
facial they are matching if it's not you
say that like different records so you
see by using that predicate blocks
method we can really reduce that bias by
huge number actually by the number of
blocks that you can find so we go from a
complexity of N squared and we divide
that n square by the number of blocks
and when you have like a million of
claim you can build millions of blogs
like that and you will look for your
matching records only within those
blocks that hopefully will have like
smaller number of records and it will be
very fast to find any matching pairs
using that the video package have a good
list of ways of finding those predicted
blocks I'm not going to describe all of
them there is like a very good
documentation about that package and the
good thing is you don't have to worry
about that it will find the best
predicate rules to build those blocks
automatically based again on that own
that a small training set that it get
when you started labeling the pears so
like I said what's most interesting
about that package is that it has a good
selection of similarity function you
have similarity function for Strings
that you can use for names you have
similarity function for for addresses
for
for like we have one for the zip codes
and again you can pick up one one
similarity function that we work with
everything or you can try to be like
more systematic and pick like the most
suitable one for every field to get a
higher accuracy they have also a clever
way of using sequel statements to
generate those predicates blocks because
and I've been able to verify that you
using just Python code to do it is not
the first way and finally for that
threshold class remember that getting
level that will allow you to say i will
stop at liberating records at this level
and these will be my clusters you don't
have to like do trial and error and try
to find out suitable they should all you
have to do is to say I want to set a
certain level of precision recall ratio
so basic what that means is do you care
more about having a very accurate list
of duplicates or what's more important
for you is to find all the duplicates
that are in your set you make that
decision you you said that so basically
you you want to find all the duplicates
and if there is like one or two records
that are not really delicate but slipped
in that record for you that's a
situation that you prefer over the other
situation where you will end up with
clusters like say have it has like five
matching records all the five are
correct but actually there is 10 of them
so you missed like half of them so it's
like a trade-off here which when you
favor the most you set up that parameter
and based on that based on the training
set it will calculate them suitable
Safehold and once we have that just
mentioned like two lines of code how to
first want to get a threshold and here
we mentioned we want like the recall to
be like twice as high as the precision
and then based on the threshold you can
start your your clustering and the less
parameter the member of maximum
components here is basically how big
the said that you want to a cluster so
this patch is really easy to use and for
the solution that we developed within
our team we we wanted leg to dupe like
millions of claims for several clients
some clients are like part of small
retail chains some other are like
national clients and they have like
really like hundreds of millions of
claims so we want a solution that will
be able to run the application on any
size of set another constraint that we
have is that since we are dealing with
protected health information data we
can't like store that data anywhere that
data is on some specific database that
audited and we can read from there we do
our our thing in memory and then we any
result that contain any health
information we need to put it back in
that same database so that was an
additional constraint for us and then we
wanted something that would be easy to
maintain and whenever we have additional
clients coming in it will be easy to add
them to a to add their data and to start
the duplicating it so these are some of
the fields that we have available and
here at just making that based on those
field that would be like the best choice
for a similarity function so you have a
string the string distance basically it
will compare two strings and say how
many differences between them it can be
like how many insertion how many
deletion how many characters are
different so this is very good function
for for anything that's like name or any
like short string there is like a
function that are very specific to
address is not very good at that it's
like similarity function for categories
and although all these are available in
the do package we ended up not using all
of them because we had to make some
trade-offs here we wanted to keep a
reasonable processing time and we did
and like be able to use like normal
computing machines to do this and at the
same time maintain an acceptable
accuracy so we had to reduce the number
of fields that we use we are
peeking just six of them the patient's
name date of birth card insurance number
the relationship number which like when
there's a family that on the same
insurance plan they would have liked 4-h
members with a different the last digit
of the the policy number will be
different and and also we use the string
function for all these fields we didn't
use any like something address specific
sort of going out to the different a
different solution that we implemented
the first one is when you first run the
deduplication process for a new client
you have to upload the data basically
you have to call you have the claims
data but you have to collect the other
information like the patient name date
of birth the zip code of the store from
different tables collect that go through
a pre-processing step because you don't
want to have like when the patient name
contains like just a coma or taste
patients something like that so you want
to clean up all these and then you build
the model and anything that's inside
that red rounded rectangle here is part
of the Danube Python library so you
build a model you do the active learning
so this is like you provide a feedback
to say usually the the dedupe
documentation it recommends like you you
label ten matching pairs and ten at
different pairs but you can go when it
appears this is like something depending
on how big is your data you need to do
more than that and then that step will
generate a model setting file so that
will be like saved in a pickle file and
then it will use or opportunity you can
use the local database I choose to use
the Postgres database here to generate
all the blocks information that step is
the one that will use the most
computations and there's like there's a
nice way to do that using like sequel
queries and once we have the list of all
these blocks and the interesting thing
is all these blocks information doesn't
have any any personal information about
the
the patients are related to the claims
and then you feed all that to the
clustering model that will come up with
a list of duplicate records the other
part that we have we had to implement
here is how to process that list of at
least of duplicate records basically we
have to prepare a list of representative
so for every cluster remember it will be
associated to one patient so we wanted
to have like representative data related
to that patient and then we need to have
the assignment so for every claim that
we have you need to assigned to one
cluster represented by that patient so
we create two tables that we move back
remember everything has to go back to
the to the same database that can
contain personal information once we do
that first initial dijo application so
we end up with having a model file that
we can reuse we end up having an initial
set of the duplication but what comes in
X is we want like to have a process that
will be like run let's say every night
that will go through the new list of
claims that ever arrived and that period
of time we didn't do any duplication and
basically we don't want to do the whole
training thing we're going to use the
same model file founded the previous
step all what needs to be done here is
based on that model and based on the
list of unique representatives that we
already have remember this is the third
option offered by the doodoo package bay
you have like a canonical a list of
representative in those claims that
arrived overnight find the one that
already exists in our list of unique
patients if you find one then update the
assignment for that claim that claim
belongs to that patient that we already
seen if it's a new claim that we can't
match to any existing patient then a new
cluster will be created that class will
complain just that that new claim so
basically this process will be like run
multiple times every time with we have
new claims we can run it
and what will happen here is the list of
cluster representative will keep
increasing as we are getting like new
patients but I will show the number most
of the claim that Rev actually are
duplicate they are belong to patients
that have already been processed the the
last thing that we do develop what we
call cluster consolidation this is
basically since the process is not
hundred percent accurate you will still
end up with having a patient associated
like to two or three clusters and we can
run this process once in a while to go
and clean up that list of representative
so if we have like two or three
representative raised to the same
patient all we need to do here is to run
the do duplicate process again but this
time we'll run it on the list of
representatives so it will be like this
is like a clinic process you have two or
three representative please merge them
under this they are really to the same
patient so merge them into one cluster
so this is like a procedure for merging
duplicate clusters or like a secondary
into duping the output for this process
will be like a list another list of
representative that will be like smaller
than the input list and then whenever we
have claims that were associated to a
cluster that was deleted because now
they belong to another one we have to
update the assignment for those claims
here I'm just giving you a what one run
of for one client for the drooping and
this is like an example of the the
predicate rules it came up with like I
said this is this is an automatic step
here based on the data that were
presented it find out that these are the
best predicate rules to generate those
blocks that will help reduce the number
of comparison one of them is just to
find the common three token or the
comments three names in the in your and
their list of Records you can see here
the number like point 60 point a these
are weights so what other rules that we
use is a simple predicate
for example the the left one when it
takes the whole zip code and build
blocks for claims that have the same zip
code for running that for different
clients basically we use the same set of
scripts of Python scripts but what we
wanted to have is a configuration file
that will contain all the information
related to the database that contained
the claims for for a certain client and
any other information that is specific
to that client basically in addition to
the database parameters we have like if
that client has specific fields that are
not the same for the other client we
will put it in in that file and the most
important thing is that where is the
model that we will use for that client
most of the most of the clients we're
dealing with I based on my experience I
found that if we generate a mod if you
learn a model for deduplication for one
client it will work pretty well for for
most of them because they using the same
the same fields but sometimes client
will have like data that's very
different from the rest and we need to
go through the same retraining and
generate a new model file for that
client so what you find like most
interesting about the solution that we
developed is that there is a thanks to
that that the cluster consolidation and
and the update the recurrent update even
if one of our update would be
interrupted it's not I mean we just have
to restart it anything that was already
transferred to the database is still
valid so what we need here is just to
restore the processing and go through
the rest of the claim that were not the
duplicated it had we try to limit
interaction with the remote ddb that had
the information about the patient the
minimum to avoid any latency and
excedrin wants a model restraint the
only thing that we need to keep is the
module definition and we don't have to
keep any personal information on the on
the server even though
we use temporary files but they all be
deleted once the training is done and
this is something that we were
successfully able to run millions of
claims and we've been able to to check
that it's not commend that that
processing time is not explained is
basically linear with the number with a
total number of representatives and
claims what can still be improved in the
solution is we stand out that it uses
quite a bit of memory for millions of
claims for now we're using to box with
16 gigabyte of memory but but we know
that we can do better especially when we
when we work with clients that have like
very large number middle hundreds of
millions of of claims what we need what
we are doing now is just reusing like a
bigger box is more memory but this is
something that we can improve and then
if you remember I mentioned that there
is like a use of postgres local database
to store the information but the
predicate blocks that part can be
replace it using the plan the sequel for
better performance this is also one on
our list of improvements for that
solution here just to give you an
example of what an assignment table will
be looking like so basically we have the
claim ID for or so for every claim you
have an ID the cluster ID that it was
associated with there's a confidence
score that will be given by the did you
up library so it this is how confident
it is that that clay claim ID belongs to
that cluster ad and then the processing
time stamp we also use that table to
identify the cluster that contained just
one claim it means that the patient made
just one order one claim we call that
the singleton clusters we identify them
with having an L confidence score
because you can define a confidence code
because there's just one element here
and then there's the new claims that are
arriving there will be just putting that
that table all their value apart from
the claim ID everything else would be
now so whenever we run the trigger
current update process it will look for
those claims that don't have any time
stamp and it will be able to them to
dedupe them and this is how the process
can be resilient with any interruption
of the update process for the
representative table it will it will be
something similar like this over this
data is not like it's not real data it
will have let the all the information
related to a patient in addition to that
cluster ID and if you go here so the
first claim ID belong to that to that
cluster idea that we are the first line
we see here so we know that any claim
that is assign it to that class ID will
it's made by this patient yeah when I so
here's some numbers about executing this
do due process so this is an example
that we ran for a client and the from
the first time you use it to point 35
million claims and the method was able
to find that there is like 2.1 claims
that are duplicates and these 2.1
million claims they are related to just
250 3,000 patients so see like ninety
percent of the data here is his
duplicates and then also 242,000 patient
that are that have just one claim here
that those we call they are non
duplicated because they've just we got a
singleton cluster so a patient that
fella just want claimed during that
period of time so in the end what we
have to create is like a 475 new cluster
representatives and that process takes
34 minutes to run other thing is to
transfer all the data back to the
database usually it takes more time so
currently using the PI ms sequel package
to move all this like to point almost
2.8 million minerals rolls I took at
like 56 minutes to move them back to the
database
another number so this is an numbers
about an update so when you have to like
to update the patient cluster
representative you have like already
five hundred sixty-two thousand claims
representative claims and you have like
1,000,000 new claims coming in you want
to match them and you find out that
950,000 are already existing and there's
just 47,000 new clusters this is the
typical number that we obtain and it
takes 24 minutes to process them and
then 24 other minutes to move them back
to the database and for one of the
clients will be we were being able to
elect to process up to 21 million claims
from 2013 to april of this year and out
of these 21 million claims we've been
able to extract one point 67 million
patient so you can see how how many
deputies in there so the next step for
us is to improve on them on the updating
the classics oh well what is called
evolution classing is that a class
related to a patient it can like become
bigger it can when you have like more
claims coming in at a certain point the
patient will change some information and
you have like to sell the little present
ative represent that cluster is no
longer up to date you need like to split
that cluster for now we are managing
through that cluster consolidate script
only to operation for for changing
clusters when we have like two classes
related to the same patient we merge
them together and also we are updating
every time we run that cluster
consolidation we update the
representative and yeah so you see
basically so he represented like this
duplication process how to use machine
learning to do it and what are the main
challenges that we've been facing and
what other trade-offs that we need to
make especially using like an exact
match in C code based operation versus
like model-based operation and
now with the constraints of always we
have to keep the smite protecting the
patient information and avoid to having
that like it I mean the data bridge
that's you think that we need to be very
careful about so that's it thank you and
please if you have any question I'll be
glad to answer